Hey Dude what's up dude dude dude dude
dude these two do you do after you're 50
do dude I'm gonna Kenyan dude dude dude
dude dude dude dude dude two dudes go
down on us to do the dude dude dude high
as the dudes go down on us same time
dude dude dude dude dude dude dude dude
dude dude dude dude damn dude
just joined the mile-high club - as I'm
leaving for the bathroom for at 40 -
dude dude dude dude dude dude dude dude
dude dude dude dude do-do-do-do-do
do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do - dude I
love hey Joe do you do you do you white
dudes are figuring out that the jig is
enough to do do you dudes dudes do you
do ya oh my god
dude dude dude dude dude dude dude - his
dick dude dude dude dude dude dude you
gentle dude dude dude dude dude dude you
do oh dude dude dude dude - dude dude
dude yeah dude carpe Daniel to talk to
YouTube dude AB dude dude dude dude dude
dude dude it is the world is good dear
did you get there dude
you don't dare do do do do do do do it
there's your dude if you did you would
be bald dude I know dude
the new season of broad city is coming
summer 2017 yes did it oh yeah are you
into hell brother
[Music]